citizens of the reject Nation we have
made it to the final episode of season
one of Reacher but there's something
very important I must communicate to
each and every one of you who have been
watching with us this entire time there
are still so many words that rhyme with
Reacher that we have yet to force into
our reactions yes this is our last
opportunity so if you were annoyed by it
prior if you thought wow they're really
trying way too hard to be funny with
words that rhyme with Reacher get ready
for it because we are doubling down did
I prepare words prior
no but we'll see what comes out of my
mouth when we're watching this so you
know what to do reach for that like
button people and if you haven't
subscribed why not why not tell me you
don't have to subscribe just tell me why
you haven't subscribed also I want to
say a massive thank you to everyone who
has joined us on our patreon via dish
this show alone who has done full-length
reaction watch-alongs We sync up with
your own copy of Reacher that is for a
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
and we cover so many things with
exclusively reaction highs and watch
alongers included are you ready to
become Jack reactor today yes I am Jack
uh reaching for a rhyme right now damage
[Music]
oh Jack Trader
try anything smart I'm gonna put a hole
right in your pals back
Jack feeler
I thought you were my friend I was
that's why I told you not to take the
job down here
Jack beseecher you and this they
couldn't let things go where's Roscoe oh
my girls doing just fine oh tied up they
want me to tell you to do what they say
or me Charlie and the kids they're gonna
do to us but they didn't Morrison cut
off their testicles
[Music]
he's on the Run thought getting lost to
protect his family yeah exactly thought
it your father promised some real bad
guys overseas a hefty amount of
counterfeit cash but thanks to the Coast
Guard blockade those boys haven't gotten
what they paid for in a while so they
sent some Venezuelan hitters to help you
pretty soon those Venezuelans are going
to give you the same necktie they gave
your daddy
shut up I killed my father oh damn we
was right whoa yeah I killed Joplin I
had that killed in the subway woof
I killed your brother
[Music]
smash him now we got a main villain yeah
you're gonna take Picard to wherever
hubbles hold up and you're gonna bring
him to me now how do you expect me to do
that you're a Tracker aren't you check
tracker
find him then I'll trade mommy and the
girls for Daddy track Reacher I don't
know how you think I'm gonna find Hubble
well yeah until sunrise tomorrow so I
suggest you figure it out I need a map
and a place to think Jack Navigator
what can I get you fellas black coffee
peach pie nothing for me it's finally
gonna get that pie give me a pen you
expect me to hand you something you can
use as a weapon
this scare you I hope he uses it I hope
to God he uses it wax Reacher on the map
Reacher so we ran off to Atlanta about
an hour from margrave Big City lots of
people makes it easy to hide Athens it's
hard for a man if he's halfway decent to
leave his family behind
it's home to University of Georgia where
Paul and Charlie went to college it's a
place directly linked to Hubble so
Augusta is next over three hours away
but still close enough he feels
connected to his wife and kids but first
he moved to Wisconsin
oh he can't just steer into
something and get inside a man's head
like that I didn't offer my help you
demanded it
from the fork give me the fork four
creature that's what I'm talking about
you better be right about Augusta
Jack puncture we should reserve it for
when we can do a full rhyme of course
anything we could go Jack Diner if we
wanted that works that's not bad
you gotta say he lived tougher than I
thought you were and you're exactly what
I thought you were
oh he's been getting his ass kicked more
than anyone else in this show
poor Finley deserves a vacation
got a flat no way we make it to Augusta
you being cute you've been with me the
whole time
laughs
beautiful delivery you think I'm gonna
leave you alone here while I go and
change the damn thing
get to work oh he knows I mean you know
there's like a title and if you're
thinking about throwing a tire in my
direction think again yeah the Fork's
still in my plan
you shoot me
I ain't the only person you're killing
yes I didn't think that through but if
you shoot me you're never finding Hubble
Dan's right
so on one we raise our guns up over our
heads on two we lay them on the trunk I
know what a gun hit metal sounds like so
don't you with me and on three we
stand up and face each other hands up
then I take two steps back and you come
get my piece whoo one
two
three
wow yep
yep yep yep Jack manipulators
hello Hubble
and we found the exact room and
everything yeah
if I was Hubble I would stay in room
number seven at this exact Motel
[Music]
ladies somebody says me your daddy's
caused us a lot of problems did you know
that
my daddy's gonna kick your ass
don't do this but I have to because you
and your friends are troublemakers you
don't have to just like the old pal gray
was a troublemaker we'll keep them
someplace safe his insurance things go
smoothly everyone who is suspiciously a
bad guy is a bad guy I know in a weird
way it's kind of refreshing how did you
find my motel I use credit cards and
Kleiner finds you so you use cash which
means travel by bus well how'd you guess
my Alias people use the names of things
they like
their plan is to kill all of us just
like they killed my brother your
treasury contact Mark Salas that's just
the name he gave you real name's Joe
played for the Yankees in the late 80s I
was trying to figure out who it was
but I would never guess that KJ kill Joe
a kid kill Joe and Morrison Stevenson
and his wife even killed his own father
real crazy cat
[Music]
if somebody's texting you buddy
what does that mean you're an idiot oh
Jack steamer
I hope you're transferring Finley
yeah seriously
like the way you die boy
oh it's good to see you alive what's at
the gun lock or the ammo safe grab
anything useful I was never able to get
replacement glasses huh no it's the one
thing they could track them the
prescription
oh I want to give him a gun he won't be
able to shoot properly no Hubble needs
all the guns this place have a hose out
back yeah why we're gonna need it
I'm thirsty
boss Neely this is Finley and Hubble yes
probably holding Roscoe and Charlie
somewhere around here what about my kids
probably up here I'll come up in there
you don't have to waste a man watching
them what if they ruin your office their
Ideal World Hubble and I get marched
through the front door and they kill all
of us they put guns outside and probably
doesn't mean inside arm to the teeth in
case I somehow go on guns blazing which
what do we do don't go in blazing that's
what I'm talking about man I've never
fired a gun all you got to do is extend
Aim Fire no point in having a weapon
unless it's ready for instance use if
you hesitate you die Point elsewhere
siphon
[Music]
Jack prayer are you Catholic
yeah Jack Preacher oh no I was reserving
that oh the only one I ever served
we can edit it out it's looking for like
some monologue or something
damn you got 20 minutes to come up with
a new one yeah I got one left you know
it's hard to tell with the suit on but
you're kind of jacked Finley
really
no there's no need to body shaming yeah
he's a competent guy all right he's
fitted enough not your size that's mean
not everyone's a cancel Jack Reacher
Jacob apologize Jack shamer man I like
it damn it did the preacher was the only
one I was like waiting for the right
time same the other one I'm not gonna be
able to use I don't see it coming up
pretty sure enough I should be in place
by now really even goes to take one of
the shots two Shooters better odds you
have experience with long range kill
shots you know
why I do
I offer Wowie
put the biscuit in the basket put the
lotion in the basket
[Applause]
they're gonna make like a giant Molotov
out of that yeah
wait I got this
ah oh I'm gonna die I wanna flavor
country one last time
yeah keep up with those Joneses how are
we gonna die let's find out
nice
Finley
Finley flick Oscar flamely
you got this buddy is that improvised it
looked very natural
[Music]
oh yeah
draft
[Music]
gun is so tiny on him so cute cute
little gun
damn look at these HD cameras these Reds
I always tell the motion of a red camera
[Applause]
yes yes
[Music]
shot yeah
oh no he actually shot one of his kids
the lock is sticking out of one of their
faces
great shot adrenaline not that easy to
shoot
it's a real satisfying action finale
[Music]
are your testicles okay
oh
camo
when a woman doesn't want to be touched
[Music]
this mother who made it back I said to
shoot him again yeah Jesus you walk the
whole way
[Music]
I was just shoot at the air condition
it's probably you know there's probably
nothing in there except pretty thin
paper push
oh yes everyone gets The Showdown they
deserve that's right
where's this cane at bash him in the
brain
oh
no no Finley
these cuts
throw the money in his face
pocket money
yeah
put your whole fist in there
you've been terminated
[Music]
oh my God
that was very satisfying she's just
trying to get on his back this whole
time
no no
don't do that
shoot him in the ass
whoa dumbass where is he I gotta go get
richer he'll be okay how do you know
that because he's richer he breathes
smoke like this on his spare time just
in case a situation like this should
arise
to go
real fire everywhere definitely real
flights this was a dangerous shoot you
guys
let me tell you a story Jack a couple
years ago
I'm on Safari in the savannah I spot
this big old rhinoceros
allowing him to track you boy
do you know that for sure
big dumbass
it's not real sport that stupid Rhino
wasn't smart enough to realize he was
over yes yes let's go Jack feeder Jack
feeder
[Music]
this guy's still talking yeah
foreign
[Music]
went from Jack speecher to Jack screamer
he survived
you've earned that shot show and Money
Shot For Real no counterfeit he never
got to have that pie I know maybe in the
last scene
he'll get it to go through the bus rider
oh look at that the love Jack lover Jack
passionate Reacher
oh don't be a jack lever
Jack sleazer Jack's loser hey that's a
good one
[Applause]
oh
Jack squeezer
a few minutes left in the show yeah
[Laughter]
something for Jack Cleaver in the five
minutes
maybe when he gets the pie
well there's some Jack cleavages the bed
right now
one last flashback let's go come over
Joe okay I'm okay John
um
no matter what you don't
You Know Jack Tierra oh Jack feeler I
can get you to the states to see experts
what did I always tell you I don't need
to solve all the world's problems and
the Richer you have the strength of
three men plus two your Natures are pure
like your hearts check nature
your grandfather's War medal got it held
it up his ass two years
[Laughter]
it takes bravery to do what's right
he does it like fearlessly
now you can cry Reacher
whoa what a defined here yeah if you
ever find yourself wandering by here
again give me a call
oh finally got her number
Jack rapper oh my God all the people who
killed Jack Reaper Jack Reaper never go
there and he's dressed in black he
should run for mayor here there's an
opening
bando
yes man that's a bummer they're so
lovely together I like the attention
detail that she's still got the yeah the
cuff bruise
I want 10 slices of peach pie give me a
repeat pie you have
is that the author of the book must be
played like a special Cameo yeah
so feds are freaking out because of a
car's involvement and all they want to
interview you what'd you tell them that
they'll never find you but they're still
in town down by the warehouse and you
kind of stand out so I'll be gone as
soon as we're done here not gonna miss
you
don't bother calling I'm gonna stay here
a few weeks help Rosco get things in
order and then I'm going home time to
stop spinning stop running away you know
Sharon would want me to live a life and
not live it alone you're here that girl
coming back I think I'm ready to take
care of someone again let's go besides I
couldn't leave Jack in the shelter
Jack yeah he needed a name and you
weren't using it reach yourself Jack it
is
one of my last official access Chief
detective you were fired a dead mess I
didn't stick so I need to right or wrong
that took place at this very spot about
a week and a half ago
the pie the pie
I hope he hates it I've had better
of course you of course you have
and grab some crayons and kill them
oh for Joe died yeah
takes bravery to solve The World's
problems too Joe boy
[Music]
you're gonna ask for a car
yeah
there's got to be one burner at that
compound at least
go back to the garage where you got that
guy's uh van doesn't say if there's a
guest appearance by Lee Childs here uh
let's see let's find out this is the
child lead just the one child like Julia
Child all right what we'll do is this
we'll just Google oh wait they're not
gonna tell us we have to go to IMDb or
Google if we want to know look up what
his name is
Lee Child yeah yeah
looks like him yeah oh look at there he
is with Thomas Cruz yeah that's
definitely him yeah right yeah let's
just type it in reach her episode 8.
yeah well done Blaze like it
I know it's like this place there are
only two reasons you play it like that
one is if he's a secret Hitman and two
as if he wrote the novels yeah
which way is this one gonna yeah
[Music]
perfect perfect sauce very satisfying
that was a very satisfying finale and it
earned all the tropes you would want in
a show like this I thought every Trope
was viciously earned right down to the
opening monologues from everyone
deciding to explain their plan to the
one guy they shouldn't explain their
whole plan too out of anyone who you
especially need them to do a solid for
them yeah ask for them to cooperate
probably shouldn't reveal the whole plan
but we needed the information and we got
there right down to the villain reveal
oh I mean we've got several villain
reveals but you know what I mean the
ultimate villain reveal yeah needed that
and then of course the action set piece
at the very end uh they built to
everything in a way
that had that release
yeah
cathartic yes that that John's favorite
word of the century oh yeah hey man when
you when you find it you gotta call it
out catharsis is hard to come by
you say it every video I know because
every video so how hard is to be very
cathartic this is such a release
I'm just drained every day from the
amount of release of tension
uh the great catharsis of that fight yes
um because a lot of times when you get
to finales like that so I shouldn't
showed some mystery heavy
oh man it just big actions
that was worth it that was rewarding it
was a good action the show has it's got
this cool realistic take it's not like
quite born identity type of fighting
that's a little bit more hyper
choreographed yeah here has a a good mix
of they got like real Marines and army
people involved or something to help out
with the choreography of like how would
they move and fight you could feel like
the really good training yeah it's
tactical it's a good realism hence I
like it I liked it a lot
um the arcs of these characters was
great and did not feel rushed I thought
it actually built to a really solid
conclusion and let's have we gotta wait
now we gotta wait we got some time to
wait no I can't wait I this was such a
nice surprise I really loved this and
yeah it felt very well-rounded and I too
appreciate a mystery that can build a
lot of its you know ultimate conclusions
you know I feel like any Mystery Show
often is like working overtime to throw
you off the scent and like give you a
million red herrings and stuff like that
and I never felt them like working too
hard to do that and like like you
pointed out most of the people
responsible like Picard is kind of a
Twist but most of the people responsible
are the people who were suspected and
it's more about like how deep did this
go and what is the context and what is
the Journey of solving the mystery and
ultimately you know bringing the truth
to light and uh and yeah I appreciated
that because I don't know just like most
Mysteries uh kind of I think give you
this outside especially crime Mysteries
this outset thing of like I'm I'm going
to suspect the least on obvious person
because they're I know they're trying to
outsmart me and I felt like this wasn't
weighed down by that no yeah not at all
and uh great characters I mean I loved
everybody like Reacher is like the
perfect centerpiece and even as he's
leaving town I'm like I'm excited to see
him interact with a new cast of
characters but I loved Roscoe and I
loved Finley and uh and even you know
supporting characters like Hubble and
Christian cruick and all that stuff like
nice presents especially Kristin cruick
sure nailed it sure she was the
highlight yeah so many scenes every
scene every moment was like on screen
you don't have to put her in Everly
scene just because she agreed to do the
show guys calm down and Roscoe was
amazing Never Gonna forget that
character yeah Finley and uh I don't
know if you guys have seen the Lethal
Weapon movies but there's a bit of a
Lethal Weapon Vibe between the two and
then we gotta see Joe sure with his hair
in the morgue I mean Joe I don't know
who that actor is who played Joe yeah I
don't know if my mind was just doing it
because of what we saw his head look
like in the morgue but I was going that
actor looks like he's wearing a wig is
he actually balding and he wears wigs
but because that's a really good set of
80s cocaine Wall Street Hair he's got
sure yeah definitely I would be curious
to know I I hadn't thought of it in the
moment but uh that's a good question
because that actor with that chiseled of
a face I'm like no no he would have a
good set of hair who played Joe in
Reacher let's see
a good set of hair this guy yeah they
just wanted you to think it was a wig as
a character choice
in here he looks great like like all
these all these photos his hair looks
amazing yeah but um yeah that that
strong hairline
uh yeah no he's uh he's a handsome fella
he's got a he's got a total um you know
not Norman Bates what's his name Patrick
Patrick Bateman thing about him oh yeah
he does look like Alan Richardson yeah
yeah they both got that that strong jaw
you know and that All-American built guy
kind of thing but you can definitely too
see how you know Joe wound up working
where he works versus Jack doing what he
does you know he's a little bit more
working with the mind and with the
system than Jack who's a little bit more
working with his hands well they've been
building up Joe for so long like he's
put on such a pedestal of the kind of
amazing god-like human being that he is
that to happen to cast an actor in there
he needs someone who can communicate
that the second you see him and I
thought they did that like the second he
walked up to him like that's got to be
Joe who did apparently gain weight and
go bald yeah I guess so well you know he
maybe he was undercover maybe they were
like people will suspect me less if I
look like a schlub yeah now let's
rewatch the Jack Reacher movie honestly
like I'm curious to see what it's
because like I remember the tones
generally and I remember being like okay
this is like a Tom Cruise joint that
goes a little bit hard uh but yeah like
I would love to catch the nuances in
comparison to this I had a really famous
car chase yes that was like what it was
mainly noted for was its car chase
sequence yeah and for giving us Jai
Courtney he's also very practical that
sequence
um yeah so that was a good moment and
the resolve that Finley comes around the
dog there's a lot of great things in
here yeah a lot of nice Tire rounds the
card Ultimate Survivor well that was a
kill boy that was that was uh that was
hard yeah but Full Sail crushed
uh that sounds a total psycho yeah oh
God they're just like monologuing
through the thing and then Jack got to
use the animal feed even that got paid
off in a fun way yeah and uh Neely Great
Character hope we see I mean I imagine
we'll see Neely again it's the one
person and I'm excited and I like that
Neely got a piece of the action too
uh you know watching the perimeter
getting into a scuffle even Hubble got a
headshot it's like it's not that easy to
shoot dude yeah we have no experience
and especially when it's burning
building through glass with your kids
next day one shot it took yeah I'll I'll
give it to him but also yeah that one
moment where I was like I feel like if
it was me and I was I was putting the
seed together I just wouldn't make it a
direct like third eye headshot I would
have made it like three shots at least
yeah yeah a few shots couple misses and
yeah it's like maybe he's in like the
throat or like some place off but that
still gets the job done yeah I just I've
always kind of I find it funny when
they're like no we're gonna do the
perfect headshot you know
yeah that was great but yeah all around
a terrific Terrific show you gotta Burn
It All To The Ground by the end yeah oh
man
it's gonna I have to readjust this is
like uh
this is like
um
uh oh man pulling names these days is so
hard for me I learned too many things
that I forget too much so much
what's his name Blanche
gonna have a same centerpiece but
different characters yeah I like that
mystery solving and then with some
action scenes I just hope next season
isn't just like let's go double the
action this time yeah I thought they
spread it out really nice I feel like in
a way you don't have to change the
general approach I think it's more about
yeah did you find a new crime and you
find a new interesting setting and maybe
some kind of other musical artist to
flavor the I don't know I mean I guess
it'll always be Blues because what Jack
likes but but yeah I feel like you don't
need to force it into being like an
action extravaganza
the atmosphere is part of the draw you
know I'm so happy this Show's a success
because I had
no faith in it when it was announced oh
because they had the movie it just
seemed like such a downgrade on from
Optics perspective you know what I mean
to go from one of the biggest superstars
in the Galaxy you know biggest
superstars in the world
I mean that second film was terrible
yeah it was never go back and watch that
show
um that was a terrible second film
and then to go to a like we're going to
make a television show with an actor
who's is nowhere near as no yeah yeah
yeah
um I did not have faith in its
announcement like I don't really care
about this I'm sure book readers are
excited like hey there's probably gonna
do a more accurate version It's a book
you know I'm sure they had a lot more
reasoning behind it but I I just wasn't
as someone who's not familiar with the
source material yeah yeah but they
nailed it they they totally outdid the
movie oh 100 yeah I think they totally
outdid it and this is definitive and to
me I don't even really want to watch the
ah watch the first one again probably
um uh yeah I mean I would only watch
never go back again as some kind of
morbid curiosity I mean Kobe smolders
she threw down for that movie like I
respected what she she tried to do with
it but uh but the first movie is like
pretty all right is is I remember liking
it and being kind of surprised that I
pretty much liked it but I wonder if the
movie hadn't come out because the Movie
allowed so many more people to be aware
of Jack Reacher like the second I heard
reach her I was like is this Jack
Reacher yeah totally totally that I
wonder if it's still somehow aided in
getting the show done well yeah I wonder
if it's a two-fold thing of people going
like okay well Tom yeah Tom Cruise
obviously made this a thing people might
be aware of and also on the heels of
that you have everyone who's been
reading these books now causing a pretty
you know just being pretty vocal and
apparent about like these movies may be
fun but they're not really like the book
yeah you know and and I think that
opportunity is is one that is pretty
vital in this day and age when you're I
feel like it's the better version of
constantly drawing from what's familiar
it's like okay what was what was all
right but could be more essentially what
it's supposed to be yeah something like
this and and two I mean yeah it's like
Alan Richardson when we learned his name
through this experience but that too
allows it to just be the character which
is a nice thing so it doesn't have to
you know you don't have to vacuum form
Jack Reacher onto Tom Cruise
amazing stuff guys I thought they nailed
it thought it was an amazing show give
it a 10 out of 10. 10. 10 out of 10 even
for sleazeball villain I would not find
to be a real threat
I thought for a second he could be when
he took you know when it's revealed that
he did all that stuff but then when it's
he's at the end and he's just like just
going around and telling his long-ass
story and uh like nah you ain't
brother I I don't I hope that for the
next season it that they give him
Again full names today
um I use it all on trying to find words
that rhyme and reach her uh what is
Sherlock Holmes's arch nemesis oh
Moriarty Moriarty he needs like a
Moriarty for next season yeah someone
who can match his intelligence sure and
then who has maybe like a military
background as well or something like
that who can no served with him there
you go yeah it's his jigsaw of the
Punisher or whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they need to make it that kind
of villain where it's a it's a cat it's
a true cat and mouse game I think like
even if whatever book They're adapting I
think whoever their main villain is has
to
be someone with a much more Superior
intelligence that would make sense yeah
somebody who somebody yeah who pushes
Jack thinks closer to how he thinks
because yeah everyone here has they have
this operation and they certainly are
formidable but they don't think the same
way you think because the fear of stakes
that really of the life or death Stakes
like of course Jack Reacher would never
die of course Watson I know you're sad
that the reacher show was done but don't
attack the other cats there will be
season two they're done shooting I think
so soon enough
um uh
uh what are we talking about
oh Jack needs a Moriarty moving forward
um
wasn't about Mel Gibson no Mel Gibson uh
he should be on the show though yeah I
think he could be the villain everyone
would love it uh something about
oh yeah the life or death Stakes they
really come in to the fear for The
Supporting Cast
not really worried about
Jack I mean not that I
it's a tall order to ask like of course
like you'd be aware but I like this I
like a good show when when you're like
of course they're not gonna die but you
like to feel like in the moment it's
really threatening you know that yeah
you want that tension yeah yeah you
always feel safest around Jack and I do
think they still manage I think they
managed to ring tension out of like
what's he gonna decide because some like
you know in that standoff with uh Picard
you know you're sort of like you're sort
of expecting he's gonna kill him but at
the same time I was like oh and I kind
of don't know how this is gonna go
um but yeah yeah having it having us
worry for Jack at least a little bit is
would be good alrighty guys well what
did you think about Reacher what would
you give it out of 10 out of 10 what
would you give it I give it a 9.8 ah
I give it a
9.853 wow yeah talk about catharsis that
is a cathartic rating I haven't had an
8.593 in a long time
9.8 whatever it's a good show my shout
someone out
I would like to shout out Andrew Hayes
Andrew Hayes you could totally see
becoming like a Jack Reacher John will
find a way to insert the lock mechanic
business that he is in he could get in
any building
there he's found really fast yeah you
get into any building disabled the
alarms and all that stuff there you go
yeah that's one aspect but at the same
time Andrew being a three foot five
stocky fella yeah never watches the
channel or checks his bank account to
see if he's still on board for his
patreon pledge hasn't changed in one bit
nope appreciate you being here Andrew
the most consistent investor and if
there's anyone who could bulk up the
fastest to get a body like Jack Reacher
it's definitely going to be Andrew oh
you'd have the muscle of Alan richson
and the height of Tom
the perfect Middle Ground
between both characters
teach us all to survive the crime
apocalypse perfect third Reacher all
around
well Andrew thank you so much for being
here please don't ever check your bank
statements and hey
shout you out again next month and
you'll have no idea that we did it
someday you're gonna find just an
avalanche
foreign